is the system of linear equations below
consistent or inconsistent and they give
us x plus 2y is equal to 13 and 3x minus
y is equal to negative 11. so to answer
this question we need to know what it
means to be consistent or inconsistent
so a consistent system of equations a
consistent system of equations
has at least
at least one solution
at least one solution
and an inconsistent system of equations
as you can imagine has no solutions
has no solutions
so if we think about it graphically what
would a what would the graph of a of a
consistent system look like
well either let me just draw a really
rough graph so that's my x-axis
and that is my y-axis
so if i have just two different lines
that intersect that would be consistent
so that's one line
and then that's another line they
clearly have that one solution where
they both intersect so that would be a
consistent system another consistent
system would be if they're the same line
because then they would intersect
they would intersect at a ton of points
actually an infinite number of points so
let's say one of the lines looks like
that and then the other line is actually
the exact same line so it's exactly
right on top of it so those two
intersect at every point along those
lines so that also would be consistent
an inconsistent system would have no
solutions so let me again draw my axes
let me once again draw my axes it will
have no solutions and so the only way
that you're going to have
two lines and two dimensions have no
solutions is if they don't intersect or
if they are parallel so one line could
look like this
and then the other line would have the
same slope but it would be shifted over
it would have a different y-intercept so
it would look like this so that would
that's what an inconsistent system would
look like you have parallel lines this
right here is inconsistent so what we
could do is just do a rough graph of
both of these lines and see if they
intersect another way to do it is you
could look at the slope and if they have
the same slope and different
y-intercepts then you'd also have an
inconsistent system but let's just graph
them
so let me draw let me draw my x-axis
and let me draw my
y-axis
my y-axis so this is x
and then this is y
and then there's a couple of ways we
could do it the easiest way is really
just find two points on each of these on
in each of that satisfy each of these
equations and that's enough to define a
line so for this first one
let's just
make a little table of x's and y's when
x is 0 when x is 0 you have 2y is equal
to 13. so when x is 0 you have 2y is
equal to 13 or y is equal to 13 over 2.
13 over 2 which is the same thing as 6
and a half six and a half so when x is
zero
y is six and a half i'll just put it
right over here so this is zero comma
thirteen
over two
and then let's just see what happens
when y is zero when y is 0 then 2 times
y is 0. you have x equaling 13
x equals 13. so we have the point 13
comma 0. so this is 0 6 and a half so 13
comma 0 would be right about there just
trying to approximate
13 comma zero and so this line right up
here this equation can be represented by
this line let me try my best to draw it
it would look something
like that
now let's worry about this one
let's worry about that one so once again
let's make a little table x's and y's
i'm really just looking for two points
on this graph
so when x is equal to zero you get na
this three times 0 is just 0. so you get
negative y is equal to negative 11 or
you get y is equal to 11. so you have
the point 0 11 so that's maybe right
over there
0 comma 11 is on that line and then when
y is 0 when y is zero you have you have
three x minus zero is equal to negative
eleven or three x is equal to negative
eleven or if you divide both sides by
three you get x is equal to negative
eleven over three
negative eleven over three and this is
the exact same thing as three negative
three and two thirds so in y zero you
have you have x being negative three and
two thirds so it would be so maybe this
is about 6 so negative 3 and 2 3 would
be right about here
so this is the point
negative 11 thirds comma zero and so the
second equation will look like something
like this
will look something like that now
clearly and you know there i might have
not been completely precise when i did
this hand drawn graph clearly these two
guys intersect they intersect right over
here and to answer their question you
don't even have to find the point that
they intersect at we just have to see
very clearly that these two lines
intersect so this is a consistent
system of equation it has one solution
you just have to have at least one in
order to be consistent so once again
consistent system of equations